let's talk about this pride what's going
on here with the pride if you heard this
they're they're saying about uh foods
that you can eat and it's getting
strange
um because on they're they're all trying
to be allies these companies you know
like the good companies of the world
and you know i'm not one of these
anti-corporate lunatics you know i i i
uh i think it's uh every now and then
corporations can do good things right
the fudgie the whale and and so so on
and so forth there's things i like now
but they're these corporations it's a
it's gay overload as a gay person i'm
telling you it's too much it's too much
now
uh whereas every corporation is
offensively gay
and it's to a point where like people
are like i don't know it's
it it it it fetishizes gay people and it
does not treat them like human beings
that's my issue with it you don't have
uh nobody's uh treated with any dignity
it's just this crass marketing scheme
tell us a little bit about what the what
they've done here at ubereats oh yeah
well the postmates commercial opposed
yeah i'm sorry well there's a lot of
them that are they're all owned by the
same company right that's true and
they're also these people are just
stepping on rakes everywhere they go
like burger king had the two equal buns
right so burger king is doing top and
bottom yeah yeah it's so crazy i mean it
is offensive but uh
because here's why it's offensive
they're saying that some people are tops
and some people are bottoms and
you could walk around like hey i'm
having a burger with two tops or it
should be here's why it's offensive what
if you're in a blood play
some people can't even come anally they
need blood play
which means that you cut someone and
lick their blood or squirt their blood
into your mouth or your eyes
if you're a bug chaser and you can only
come
thinking you could get aids you want
aids where is the meal for you
there's some people that can only get
off being pissed on some people like
[ __ ]
where is their men do they have a menu
for people that like [ __ ] play uh yes
hey bobby can you i just emailed it to
you there's a bottom pride postmates
commercial if you could play it yeah
bottom pride which is i guess if you eat
a lot of yogurt here's what i found you
can get [ __ ] in the ass after eating
really anything
it doesn't really matter it's just an
[ __ ] it doesn't really matter stop
trying to make it so nice for the other
person
um
here is this about what you should eat
before you get [ __ ] in the ass
what are you eating this pride
anything if you're a top it seems like
you can eat whatever you want
but if you're a bottom you're expected
to starve
not this pride introducing the bottom
friendly menu from postmates
what's on that we teamed up with dr evan
goldstein from bespoke surgical to bring
you a menu of bottom friendly foods
backed by science
insoluble fiber won't help you feel cute
so avoid things like whole grains sweet
bran cauliflower potatoes legumes
hold up are you just fully diving into
those beans
the problem with these foods is they
don't dissolve in water which could
cause a traffic jam in your digestive
system the deal
you can get [ __ ] in the ass after
eating potatoes
right
i mean
i don't understand a problem
i mean you
i usually i mean there's only real
problems with that when like you eat
something crazy
you know but i think for them you don't
have to just eat yogurt the whole day
you can just go on about your life and
then just get [ __ ] in the ass and the
worst thing that happens is i guess you
would just [ __ ] on someone's dick
which it's not that a nice thing to do
but if you do it i mean what i mean
what's the problem but my concern about
all this here is it reduces gay people
to number one it's all sex it's there's
nothing about it you know you wouldn't
do this to any other group of people
you know right would you do this on
black history month and have like an
anti-diabetes diet
and go hey let's hold it down with the
soul food this month
don't you want to be around next black
history month
how about some salads
why would you would you do that you
couldn't do it wouldn't be right
wouldn't be right
so i just think this is strange and i
also think like if you're gonna have
what about trans and non-binary and
why not every gender should have some
type of menu
you know
what about the menu for a [ __ ] you
know
[ __ ]
sapiosexual
demi plebes that like to be dominated
what about that
what about the bdsm menu what kind of
foods should i eat before i'm choked on
the stairs
is there an is there a type of panini i
should eat before i cut off your oxygen
and watch you squirm like a fish
because that's the only way i can come i
can't come unless you're fighting for
air
like someone that's collapsed in the
rubble of the twin towers
what is the appropriate hot dog to eat
before that anything
but these companies here's what i'm
saying these companies
are bobby order us at pizza is anyone
getting [ __ ] in the ass tonight
do they have a problem with pizza